Hola como
tu estas
Y allá
[Música]
I
me quedaré
por aquí
[Música]
Y allá
O
que no puede quedarse como está
una ciudad abandonada es un apocalipsis es
llorar y
Y allá
Es
el esposo grita como puedes ver aqui
cierto Han pasado 15 días para venir aquí y tomar
unos 3 a 4 metros en 15 dias ese amarillo
también, para que la gente no sepa sobre este muro
él está aquí puede la semana que viene no
Se acabó aquí, ya estoy
hacer arreglos para el arrendamiento de otro
vivienda para sacar a mi familia de aquí
que yo tambien no puedo poner este Rios
[Música]
Hice una propuesta que muestra la
transporte de das Areias artificiales que
se depositan en el interior de las arenas de los ríos
que son Arenas idénticas de las que podrían
ser transportado artificialmente Y con
esto recompone el ecosistema de Paraibuna
que es una línea natural de defensa para el
avance del mar en
Y allá
[Música]